As a warm-up, just to see how to
use steady-state probabilities,
let us look at our
familiar example.
This is a two-state
Markov chain,
and we did write down the
complete balance equations
for this chain, and found the
steady-state probabilities
before.
Notice that we can find these
by using the trick which
we introduced for birth
and death processes.
You cut the chain
along this line,
and argue that the frequency
of transition of this type
has to be the same as the
frequency of transition
of this type.
So if you have pi 1
here and pi 2 here,
what it means is pi 1
times 0.5, which represent
the frequency of these
kind of transitions,
has to be equal
to pi 2 times 0.2,
which is this kind of
transition, plus pi 1
plus pi 2, the
normalization equation.
And by solving the
system of equations,
you obtain the same thing
as what we obtained before,
which is the steady-state
probabilities of state 1
and of state 2.
Let us now try to calculate
some related quantities.
Suppose that you
start at state 1,
and you want to calculate
this particular probability.
So you start at
state 1, and you want
to know what is the
probability that next time you
will be in state 1, and 100
times step later, you are still
in state 1.
Now, the conditional
probabilities
of two things happening is
the conditional probability
of the first one
happening, x1 equals
1, given x0 equals 1, and given
that the first one happens,
the probability that the second
one happened-- x100 equals 1,
given x1 equals 1,
and x0 equals 1.
So what is this?
This first one is the transition
probability from state 1
to state 1, p 1 1.
How about the
second probability?
Because of the Markov property,
that information is irrelevant,
and so that probability
is r 1 1 in 99 steps.
Now, 99 is possibly
a big number,
and so we approximate
this quantity,
and we are going to use the
steady-state probability
of state 1 for doing that.
And that gives us an
approximation, p 1 1,
times pi of 1, which, then,
is 0.5 times 2 over 7.
Now, how about this expression?
Given that you start
in state 1, what
is the probability that at
time step 100, you are in 1,
and time step 101 you are in 2.
By doing the same
technique gives
the conditional probability
of the first thing happening,
and then, given that
thing happening,
the probability that
the second one happen.
x101 equals 2, given x100
equals 1, and x0 equals 1.
And again, here what we
have is r 1 1 of 100,
and times-- again,
the Markov property
tells us that we can
forget about this one--
and this is the probability
transition from 1 to 2, pi 1 2.
And again, here, if n
equals 100 is large enough,
we can approximate that
by pi 1 times p 1 2.
And this, then, 2 over
7 times 0.5 again.
Finally, let's calculate
this third expression, where,
again, we start at state
1, and now we are asking,
what is probability that after
time step 100, you are in 1,
and 100 steps later,
you are again in 1?
We use the same trick as
before, this probability
that the first thing
happened, and given that,
the probability of the
second one happened.
Again, this is r 1 1
of 100, and this one,
for the same reason as before,
we can forget this term.
From 100 to 200, you have
100 time steps, r 1 1 of 100.
And 100 is big
enough, so we're going
to approximate both
by the same values,
and we get pi 1 square,
which is 2 over 7 square.
Now, in this calculation,
we assume that n equals 99,
or n equals 100 were
big enough-- big
enough so that the
limit has taken effect.
But how do we know that
our approximation is good?
In other words, is n equals
99 or 100 large enough?
Well, this has something
to do with the mixing time
scale of our Markov chain,
and by mixing time scale,
I mean, how long does it
take for the initial states
to be forgotten?
So how can you see that here?
Well, you can first
try a simulation.
So using any of your
favorite software, simulate.
If you calculate, and you
look at, as a function of n,
and you draw r 1 1 of n,
at n equals 0, this is 1.
n equals 1, then you
have 5, et cetera.
At 1, this is going to be
p 1 1, and p 1 1 was 0.5,
so already it's here.
So initially it was here, here.
And 2 over 7, so this is 0.5.
2 over 7 is here.
And what we know is that
when n goes to infinity,
these things goes to 2 over 7.
And if you simulate, you will
see that it goes very fast.
So with you, I'm
just joining points,
and we will see that
n equals 5 already.
You are very, very
close to 2 over 7.
So you have really an
exponential decrease here.
In fact, if you look at
the simulation result,
and you look at n
equals 5 already,
here you have two
correct decimal already.
And for n equals 10, it's
correct up to five decimals.
Or, if you do not want to
have simulation, but simply
think in terms of order
of magnitude-- so here
it would be another
approach would
be order of magnitude
type of argument--
and in order to do
that, starting here,
on average, how many trials,
or how many time steps
would it take in order for you
to observe such a transition
here?
Well, you use the
geometric, random variable,
and this is the amount
of time, on average,
until you have success.
And it is 1 over the
probability here,
so it takes an average two time
steps to go from here to here.
And to go from here to
here, it takes, on average,
1 over 0.2, which is
about five time steps.
So as an order of
magnitude, given
you started here in state
1, after, on average,
about 10 iterations, there
will be some randomness.
There is a high
likelihood, on average,
that you will go
there and come here.
And then if you do
n equals 100, which
is 10 times that, in terms
of order of magnitude,
it looks like n is large enough.
So that would be a back to
the envelope calculation.
Now, this kind of calculation
is useful in general, not just
here.
So for example,
let's do it again.
Assume that instead of 0.5 here,
the probability that you had
was 0.999.
And maybe here, instead
of 0.8, it was 0.998.
Now, in order to observe
such a transition,
it will take, on average,
since this number here
would become 0.001,
it would take,
on average, about
1,000 time steps
in order to observe
one such transition.
So if you look at time
steps of that order,
it will not be enough if
your chain were of this type.
After n equals
100, the likelihood
would be that you
will still be here,
so the initial state, or
the initial condition,
would matter still.
So you would take about
1,000 to get there,
and then here it
would have 0.002.
That means that, on
average, from here you
would take about 500
iterations before you observe
that for the first time, so
the same order of magnitude.
So in order to get
enough randomness here,
a good rule would be to
multiply this 1,000 by 10.
So maybe with n
equals 10,000, you
would feel confident enough,
in that specific case,
in order to use this
kind of approximation
that we have used here.
And finally, for
those interested,
you can study that by theory.
And here there is
an entire field
that try to study how fast
a Markov chain converges
to steady state, and the
so-called mixing time.
And it turns out that
for these Markov chain,
you can say that the
convergence, or the rate
of convergence,
is of the order c
at the power n, where c is a
number that is between 0 and 1.
And the closer c is to 1, the
slower the convergence is.
And the closer c is to 0, the
faster the convergence is.
And for example, here,
for our initial case,
the c was 0.3, so that
was the first case
for the second chain.
With these kind of
probabilities, 0.99 and 0.998,
the c would be 0.997.